[Music]
still get their waterproof mascara
Hannah brown and Tyler Cameron are still
hanging out in Florida it's been you
know life-changing while the majority of
the nation is implementing social
distancing amid the corona virus
outbreak
the former exes are spending their time
filming at tic toc videos with their
friends seemingly back on couple even
started a new social media account with
their buddies called the quarantine crew
in their first video the group of four
guys and four girls danced to Megan the
stallion song savage the ladies were
rocking their teeny bikinis for the vid
[Music]
while the guys showed off some serious
abs in their swimsuit trunks mess around
and danci hood out earlier this week the
27 year old model and the former
Bachelorette star were spotted on the
beach together after Tyler picked up
Hannah from the Palm Beach Airport I
hope she knows I'll pretty much do
anything for her this trip marks
Hannah's second - Tyler's home state in
the past two weeks she traveled down to
South Florida to be with Tyler shortly
after his mother and Ria's sudden death
but are they back on he just has a
gentle spirit about him although there's
been no official announcement just yet
it's safe to say bachelor nation is
definitely rooting for Tyler and Hannah
to get back together time to really
focus on my love life
you